bienvenue à vous tous qui le rejoignent
est au coeur de l'info du ray ce soir
donc sommes nous trop sur la planète
cette question est taboue elle met mal à
l'aise car elle fait penser notamment
aux dictatures et que surtout on n'a pas
vraiment la réponse est pourtant en ce
début de qom 23 vient d'être soulevée
par les quinze mille scientifiques
signataires d'un nouvel appel pour
sauver notre planète nous allons en
débattre avec nos invités jean marc
jancovici ingénieur consultant en
énergie climat vous êtes l'un des
fondateurs de lagence carbone 4 est
enseignée à l'école des mines
votre dernier livre dormez tranquilles
jusqu'en 2100 est paru chez odile jacob
avait le bras et louis historien et
démographe directeur d'études à l'école
des hautes études en sciences sociales à
pour ce soir deux de vos livres
archéologie des migrations aux éditions
la découverte mais aussi l'âge des
migrations paru chez autrement
enfin nous sommes aussi en duplex de
bonn où se déroule la coop 23 avec
françois gemenne spécialiste des
questions de géopolitique et
d'environnement vous enseigne à sciences
po et à l'université de liège est
l'auteur d'un atlas des migrations
environnementales aux presses de
sciences po
même la croix 6 mai
hervé le braz faut-il limiter la
population pour sauver la planète
une question qui avant enfin on n'osait
même pas la poser parce qu on pense
immédiatement à des mesures drastiques
et quasi dictatorial alors oui ils ont
pour lui a posée quand même très très
très vite deux déjà en 1960 un ecologgia
professeur d'écologie de stanford paul
ehrlich recommandait de ramener la
population de la planète a à peu près un
milliard d'habitants
la difficulté c'est de trouver un
chiffre est au même moment où paul
ehrlich donné un milliard comme un
maximum le professeur qui dirigeait le
département d'agriculture à harvard en
hervelle donnait 50 milliards parce
qu'il avait une façon tout à fait
différente de calculer c'est combien on
peut produire au maximum donc entre les
deux c'est très compliqué de dire avant
même de faire une répartition de dire
même globalement et 1 combien il faut de
d'habitants un autre démographe
américains de l'université rockefeller
joel coen a consacré un livre à toutes
les estimations scientifiques du maximum
soutenable de population il en a relance
ans il en a recensé 70 qui ça commence
au de fin du xviie siècle et sa
s'échelonnent à peu près de 1,1 milliard
à 50 milliards ça descend un peu d'eau
dessous d'un milliard avec le commandant
cousteau
oui c'est à 600 millions alors bon il ya
quand même une forme de petits jeux en
même temps là on a quinze mille
scientifiques qui nous disent écoutez
c'est une question qui mérite d'être
posée et elle est sérieuse on a envie de
vous dire très simplement
jean marc jancovici c'est si c'est
l'homme qui polluent sommes nous trop et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
éventuellement pour diminuer le nombre
d'êtres humains sur terre mais voyez
rien de le dire je suis je suis voilà
vous êtes gênés en france mais si vous
étiez en angleterre en australie le zéro
population une grosse et très populaire
depuis très longtemps mais la france un
passé ce qu'on appelle populatio nist on
a toujours pensé qu'on manque donc on
manquait d'habitants comme enquête
population et ce depuis la fin du 19e
siècle mais dans les autres pays ça
plutôt est l inverse on a les anglais
ont été malthusien comme on dit d'elle
19e siècle ça veut dire quoi
quand on veut dit quand on dit ils sont
malthusien
veut dire que alors c'est pas du tout
mais la théorie de malthus quand la vie
malthus mais quand on dit il son match
bien ça veut dire qu'ils veulent que en
stop la croissance de la population
qu'on arrive à aux héros population
crous alors jean majeau ici une question
évidemment c'est une question mais c'est
une question qui a peu de clients parce
qu'il n'y a pas de patron de la planète
donc c'est une étape c'est
nécessairement un objet d'interrogation
hier c'est légitime de se poser la
question maintenant il faut qu'on a la
réponse
il n'y a pas une personne bien
individualisé qui sait en faire quelque
chose parce que les états sont
souverains et parce qu'en plus on touche
là à des choses qui sont pas du tout
purement rationnel et à l'intimité les
questions religieuses qui parcourt la
planète sont aussi très importantes
enfin bon si on prend le point de vue de
l'objet d'études
on est très très analytique il ya en ce
qui concerne toutes les espèces vivantes
soit dit en passant une notion de
capacité de charge
c'est à dire que vous êtes sur une
planète je prends la planète elle fait
très demi kilomètre de diamètre pour
l'apprendre ap il a une superficie
données et vous regardez combien vous
pouvez mettre de gens dessus évidemment
vous avez des conditions aux limites ça
dépend ce qu'ils mangent plus vous
manger de viande plus vous avez besoin
de surfaces agricoles il ça dépend de ce
que vous avez envie de laisser à la
forêt et aux petits oiseaux
ça déborde et ça dépend combien temps
vous avez envie durer parce que vous
pouvez très bien vous dire l'expérience
ça va bien si elle dure 50 ans je m'en
fiche mais vous pouvez aussi vouloir
dire j'ai envie que ça dure trois
siècles et à ce moment les conditions
aux limites sont pas les mêmes donc je
rejoins ce qui vient des dix se mettre
d'accord sur un chiffre
il ya une forme face à c'est un débat
presque sans fin parce que on va jamais
avoir la même acceptation des conditions
aux limites qui vont derrière elle et si
je vous dis faudra bien qu'on se mettre
d'accord un moment ou un autre mais
alors là où je vous rejoins sur cette
façon de voir les choses un peu
fataliste c'est que ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'à partir du moment où vous dépasser
la capacité de charge compte tenu du
niveau de vie et compte tenu des
ressources de l'environnement à un
moment le système se régule et alors
quand le système se réguler
là ça se fait en général d'une façon qui
est pas très sympathique pour la
population parce que les trois grands
modes de régulation de la population
c'est la famine la maladie la guerre oui
donc la caisse le débat là où il devient
vraiment intéressant c'est qu'est-ce qui
est le plus désagréable si on est
fermement convaincue qu'on a dépassé
cette fameuse capacité de charge c est
ce que on s'impose des mesures dont
certaines sont quand même pas
affreuse contraception par exemple c'est
pas quelque chose qui est totalement
affreux est ce que on discute des
mesures de prévention entre guillemets
ou bien on se dit bon advienne que
pourra
pour le moment on a envie de jouir de la
vie telle qu'elle se présente et on
verra bien plus tard françois gemenne
merci beaucoup d'autres avec qui je
rappelle que vous êtes en direct de
bonnes puisque vous participez à la co
on en parle de cette question de la
régulation de la population à bonn n'a
pas du tout c'est un tabou c'est
inacceptable pour les pays en
développement
bien entendu les pays en développement
voient cette question comme une manière
pour les pays industralisés de faire
peser sur eux la charge de l'effort
puisque aujourd'hui 70 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre sont émises par
uniquement un milliard d'habitants pour
les pays en développement
c'est une question qu'il n'est pas
possible de poser parce qu'il le verrait
comme quelque chose que le nord veut
leur imposer pour se dédouaner de ses
responsabilités et c'est vrai qu
effectivement faire peser la
responsabilité et du changement
climatique sur la croissance
démographique a ses limites puisque
aujourd'hui le continent qu'est la plus
forte croissance démographique l'afrique
est aussi le continent qui est la plus
faible croissance de ses émissions de
gaz à effet de serre les seuls qui en
ont parlé il y a quelques années c'était
les la délégation chinoise qui essaient
d'utiliser sa politique de l'enfant
unique comme une politique climatique en
disant regardez moi j'ai déjà fait
l'effort dans le passé j'ai limité ma
démographie et donc vous devez me
demander maintenant moins d'efforts
parce que j'ai déjà produit cet effort
dans le passé mais à part les chinois
personne ne veut véritablement en parler
parce que de surcroît se pose aussi la
question politique quand bien même on se
mettrait d'accord son actif la question
c'est comment faire concrètement comment
est-ce que vous limiter les naissances
on l'a dit les trois moyens de
régulation de la population
c'est la famine ou louer ou la guerre ou
les maladies et personne évidemment ne
veut cela donc il ya aussi un véritable
problème politique
quand bien même on pourrait discuter de
ces questions dans les négociations
ce qui n'est pas le cas pour le moment
la seule chose dont on peut discuter
c'est de la distribution géographique de
cette population
en d'autres termes où les gens pourront
ils habitent et demain et quels seront
les zones du monde qui resteront
habitable et où est ce qu'on va placer
les gens
hervé le bras oui il faut aussi je crois
un haut fond
quinze mille scientifiques sont des
biologistes et pas des spécialistes de
sciences sociales et donc ils ont un peu
tendance à traiter les humains comme
s'il s'agissait au fond d'animaux et
d'insectes
or les choses sont très différentes
d'abord parce qu'elles sont très
différentes entre les pays
en fait sur la grande majorité
maintenant dans la grande majorité des
pays la fécondité est devenu très modéré
et même souvent au dessous de 2 enfants
par femme ce mettons le cas dans des
pays comme le brésil comme la chine
et c'est en train de le profond c'est en
train de devenir la règle sur la planète
donc il faut spécifier le problème et
c'est pas un énorme problème c'est à
dire il ya deux pôles qui sont assez
limités c'est l'afrique intertropicale
et la zone nord de l'inde nord du
pakistan afghanistan
donc là ce qui serait sérieux c'est à
dire on va avoir une police si on veut
vraiment limiter la population
restreindre l'accroissement
démographique
on va avoir une politique spécifique
c'est pas énormément de monde
actuellement le sahel c'est un peu moins
de 100 millions d'habitants sur plus de
7 milliards donc là dedans il ya un truc
un certain manque de sérieux de faire un
raisonnement général sur la croissance
démographique est pas voir les cas
particuliers qui se pose alors sur ce
qu'on peut appeler l' alerte
démographique on reviendra avec un
portage en quelques instants
si j'ai bien compris ce que vous nous
avez dit françois gemenne finalement
actuellement à bonn
on ne parle en gros que de co2 on parle
de co2 et on parle surtout de plus en
plus des dommages liés au changement
climatique de la manière dont on fait
financer les solutions d'adaptation est
évidemment la question de la migration
s'intègre dans ce débat sur les
conséquences du changement climatique
on a raison de parler de co2 à 20 dans
une réunion annuelle qui vise à parler
de changement climatique c'est difficile
de ne pas en parler
selon yu cela étant il faut bien voir
que dans une manifestation telle que la
coop alors moi je suis pas cette année
mais enfin j'imagine que les ordres de
grandeur sont toujours les mêmes il ya
quelques milliers de personnes qui sont
chacune investit en général de discuter
d'un petit bout mais détaché de la
question avec une mise en cohérence
globale au moment de la discussion à peu
près personne n'est capable de faire
donc si vous essayez à un instant t de
deee
à quoi se résume la discussion en ce
moment à part vous dira quelques
milliers de personnes qui discutent les
unes avec les autres en groupe de
n'importe quoi qui va de 2 à 100
personnes
rien d'autre et par ailleurs dans ce
genre d'enceinte
c'est très compliqué d'interpréter les
résultats en sortie parce que je
rappelle que ça produit des accords qui
sont non contraignant il ya pas de
gendarmes pour vérifier que vous êtes
bien en train de faire il ya personne
pour vous coller une amende si vous
faites pas ce que vous avez dit que vous
feriez j'imagine qu'on en parle à
l'heure mais c'est donc c'est un ca
c'est un endroit qui en gros éveille
l'intérêt et dire beaucoup plus que ça
surtout à chaud malheureusement c'est
très difficile alors vous ne savez
peut-être pas mais ce sont les îles
fidji qui co-organise la com' 23 pour
limiter la facture carbone tout cela se
passe à bonn en allemagne les
représentants donald kohn ont fait le
déplacement pour vanter les mérites du
charbon et du pétrole
bref tant pis pour les îles fidji menacé
de disparition françois xavier rigo
cérémonie d'ouverture de la coop 23 à
bonn en allemagne sous la présidence les
îles fidji menacés de disparition par la
montée des eaux
ni le besoin d'agir urgemment est
évident notre monde est en détresse face
aux phénomènes météorologiques extrêmes
causés par le changement climatique
ouragans destructeurs incendies
inondations sécheresses fonte des glaces
en marge de cette coop 23 la délégation
américaine envoyé par donald trump
organisé une conférence pour vanter les
mérites des énergies fossiles dans la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
donald trump veut utiliser toutes les
ressources dont dispose notre pays pour
créer des emplois aux etats-unis et
permettre à nos entreprises d'être plus
compétitives
le président veut également que nos
ressources en énergie puisse t dé nos
alliés et partenaires en matière de
sécurité énergétique
il existe aujourd'hui des technologies
qui peuvent permettre de réduire
drastiquement les émissions liées à la
production de charbon et autres énergies
fossiles sans science washington
persiste dans son choix de tourner le
dos à la corde paris sur le
réchauffement climatique
mais la conférence américaine a
rapidement viré au fiasco pour les
membres de la délégation très peu à la
surprise générale de gouverneurs
démocrates américains ont fait irruption
dans la salle pour dénoncer les choix de
l'administration américaine en matière
énergétique
c'est un spectacle ridicule le monde ne
vous regarde pas le monde ne prêtera pas
attention à quelqu'un qui affirme que le
changement climatique est une farce
donald trump l'essai de vous vendre des
vieilles technologies d'un monde passer
d'un monde révolu avec des arguments
scientifiques erronée c'est absolument
évident que trump rejette l'économie du
futur
pire encore quelques minutes plus tard
des dizaines d'activistes ont interrompu
la conférence
[Musique]
ils ont entonné un chant contre la
production de charbon ayem kg 1
je suis ici parce que étant jeune j'ai
peur de la menace mais changement
climatique
je suis en colère que des personnes
comme donald trump mettre nos vies nos
futurs en danger les états unis devaient
respecter la liberté et la justice pour
tous ces scandales et chippis le vrai
rêve américain pas le rêve de quelques
milliardaires et des ans % les plus
riches
c'est l'administration trempe rejette
les accords de paris des états des
villes des entreprises américaines ont
décidé de s'engager à respecter ces
accords en réduisant leurs émissions et
en développant les énergies
renouvelables
hier que le peuple américain lui est
engagé dans ses objectifs et washington
ne peut rien faire pour nous arrêter
de nombreuses villes et états ont même
déjà pris des engagements concrets en
matière de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
43 villes se sont déjà engagées à passer
à 100% d'énergies renouvelables et cet
été lors de la conférence des maires qui
représente les 1200 plus grande ville
des etats unis ils se sont eux aussi
engagés dans le même sens
sous l'impulsion de donald trump de très
nombreuses mines de charbon ouvert sur
le sol américain
et pour la première fois depuis 1975
les etats-unis sont à nouveau les
premiers producteurs de pétrole pour la
première fois depuis 1975
les etats-unis sont à nouveau premier
pays producteur de pétrole au monde
cette notion quand même devrait nous
interpeller comment vit-on françois
gemenne depuis bonn dans cette comme 23
le vrai bras d'honneur de la délégation
américaine et du président preuve c'est
certain que c'est une débandade complète
ici à bonn pour la délégation américaine
parce qu'en réalité il ya deux
délégations
il ya la négation officielle de donald
trump qui multiplie les provocations
d'abus dans le reportage
cette promotion des énergies fossiles
c'est comme si vous alliez un congrès
contre le cancer faire la promotion du
tabac dans la lutte contre le cancer
c'est une pure provocation
et puis il ya délégation la société
civile des autorités locales des
gouverneurs des états qui le proclame
que les états unis sont toujours dans
l'accord de paris et vos parvenir à
atteindre les objectifs malgré le
retrait du gouvernement fédéral
américain et donc on a une délégation
contre l'autre il ya par exemple un
pavillon officiel des états unis
et puis un pavillon non-officiel qui est
ici à quelques encablures juste d'air le
centre de presse international
le problème je dire dans la négociation
c'est que les états unis en réalité ne
sont pas isolés du tout ce qui se passe
pour le moment dans la négociation est
assez dramatique puisqu'il ne se passe
rien au niveau macro c'est comme si on
avait une multitudes myriade de petites
initiatives de petits accords mais dans
la négociation globale
il ne se passe quasiment rien comme si
l'accord de paris était un point
d'arrivée plutôt qu'une ligne
départ et donc par exemple les états
refuse de revoir à la hausse leur
engagement avant 2020 or c'est pourtant
une condition sinequanone si l'on veut
atteindre les objectifs de l'accord de
paris est donc quelque part là comme 23
est en train d'enterrer définitivement
l'objectif des deux degrés et là c'est
véritablement dramatiques alors je
trouve que vous faites un très bon
correspondant à bonn néanmoins je
reviens tout petit peu sur les états
unis
est ce que ça veut dire d'une certaine
façon que par rapport aux objectifs
annoncés
on peut faire sans l'état américain mais
avec l'ensemble des grandes villes et
des bonnes volontés pour obtenir ces
résultats est ce que c'est raisonnable
de l'imaginer c'est refaire sans donald
trump et sans washington juste athènes
façon mais avec toutes les bonnes
volontés qui se font entendre et qu'ils
se mettent en pratique dès aujourd'hui
aux états unis
je voudrais y croire et il est certain
qu'il y a plein de choses qui se passent
dans la société civile américaine
plein de villes plein d'état qui
aujourd'hui ont décidé de réduire
effectivement leurs émissions mais le
gouvernement fédéral conserve des
leviers très très important à la fois
par exemple sur le financement des fonds
pour le climat sur le financement de la
recherche
on voit bien que les fonds alloués à la
recherche sur le climat sont en train
d'être saborder aux états unis le
gouvernement peut également ré investir
dans le pétrole dans le charbon c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer et puis
bien entendu il ya le poids diplomatique
des états unis on sait aujourd'hui que
tout le monde doit appuyer sur
l'accélérateur et ils sont très
difficile de demander aux autres
délégations d'appuyer sur l'accélérateur
si les états unis font marche arrière
tout le monde est un peu en train de
dire aux faux pourquoi devrions nous
revoir la hausse nos engagements si les
etats-unis eux ne font rien et se place
dans la position du passager clandestin
oui en fait il se retourne dans une
situation où ils découragent toutes les
bonnes volontés qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce qui se passe là-bas
notamment avec la voilà cette délégation
américaine
moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'on accordait
plus d'importance à l'état fédéral
américain qui n'en méritait vraiment les
français qui sont habitués à un pays où
l'exécutif est très fort oui puisque
chez nous c'est le gouvernement cas lors
du jour du parlement c'est le
gouvernement qui fait les projets de
lois etc ne comprends pas qu aux etats
unis c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça
se passe est beaucoup plus décentralisée
ne le sait pas c'est autonome
c'est-à-dire que le parlement décide de
son propre ordre du jour
il n'y a pas la notion de décret
circuler loi comporte leurs propres
décrets dans les textes ont mille pages
etc
et c'est la raison pour laquelle obama
en huit ans il a réussi à faire voter
une loi forte parce que faire voter une
loi forte aux etats-unis c'est un chemin
de croix qui est absolument
extraordinaire
donc en fait trump il à l'importance
qu'on lui donne quelque part quand on
regarde par ailleurs les sous jacents
aux états unis qui explique ce qui se
passe dans l'économie américaine
en fait ce que dit ou ne dit pas le
président on n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance
la raison pour laquelle les opérateurs
de chez l'oeil les shales gas ont foré
des trous partout ne doit pas grand
chose à ce qu'obama a fait et ne devra
pas grand chose à ce que 30 peu fait
c'est un système qui a sa propre logique
qui est arrivée par ailleurs et en ce
qui concerne vous voulez dire que
n'importe qui peut creuser où il le veut
oui parce que le droit minier ans aux
etats-unis c'est que si vous êtes
propriétaire du sol vous êtes
profitèrent du sous-sol d'accord donc
donc monsieur calvi à une parcelle de
terre aux états unis demain matin vous
pouvez y ait un foreur vient de chez moi
à creuser un trou et on va regarder s'il
ya quelque chose
et s'il ya quelque chose on se partage
le résultat d'accords vous n'avez pas
besoin de l'autorisation de l'état pour
ça vous me donner des idées
c'est inhabituel nulle part ailleurs
dans le monde ça se passe comme ça oui
c'est bon il a dit quelque chose de la
civilisation américaine star ailleurs il
faut savoir les opérateurs de pétrole de
schiste aux états unis depuis que cette
industrie existent ils n'ont pas gagné
un dollar ils ont perdu en cumulé
quelques centaines de milliards de
dollars
on nous a expliqué par un + b que ça
avait relancé l'économie américaine sait
pas qui est on met en tout cas la chose
que je peux vous dire il y avait un
article dans le financial times n'ya pas
longtemps pour citer un de vos confrères
qui est qui donnait ce qu'on appelle des
cash-flows et pertes en cash flow depuis
le début de cette industrie et ils ont
perdu quelques centaines de milliards de
dollars donc d'aller creuser un peu ce
qui se passe aux etats unis est quelque
chose qui réserve une fois qu'ils
montent une complexité bien supérieur à
30 pas dis donc il va se passer ça ou
obama avait dit et donc il va se passer
l'un verse ce qui est sûr par contre
c'est qu'aux états unis l'action se
passe à l'étagé en dessous
oui donc les gens avec qui il faut
vraiment discuté aux états unis si on a
envie que ça bouge c'est des entreprises
et les états ce qu'est ce que vient de
dire françois gemenne c'est exactement
ça alors avant de découvrir le deuxième
reportage de cette émission que je
voulais me livrer un petit jeu est ce
que vous souvenez quand vous étiez
l'école que communal audit primaire
le chiffre de population mondiale que
l'on vous apprenait hervé lebras devrait
le savoir mais on était du côté de 2
milliards de livres et demi c'est vous
on va être à 3 oui moi je crois qu'on
était à cas déjà pour moi françois
gemenne vous
on était à 6 quand j'étais au lycée hier
quand vous étiez au lycée en 25 ans en
tout cas la population mondiale a
augmenté de 2 milliards et ce n'est pas
terminé l'une des recommandations
avancées nous l'évoquions il ya quelques
instants par ses 15000 scientifique
consiste à limiter la population pour
préserver l'environnement
ça paraît logique et en même temps ça
fait peur dossier préparé par antoine
magnan et basile bonne vingt-cinq ans
après les scientifiques du monde entier
monte au créneau
vingt-cinq ans après le sommet de la
terre de rio en marge duquel 1700
scientifique signait un premier
avertissement à l'humanité
cette année ils sont cette fois quinze
mille deux cent quatre-vingt quatre pays
différents à mettre de nouveau en garde
rien ne s'est amélioré et pire encore
les problèmes se sont considérablement
aggravée cet appel relayé par le
quotidien le monde pointe la question de
la surpopulation humaine
la croissance démographique rapide et et
continue est l'un des principaux
facteurs des menaces
en montagne
[Musique]
une progression vertigineuse depuis 1992
la population mondiale a augmenté de
deux milliards d'habitants
et ce n'est pas fini elle dépassera les
10 milliards avant la fin du siècle
francorchamps est l'un des premiers
signataires de l'appel comme les autres
scientifiques
il pointe le problème de la démographie
problèmes de population humaine
c'est la base de tous les autres
problèmes
on est trop nombreux et chacun on
consomme trop une surpopulation qui
amènera un problème de gestion des
ressources
c'est ce qui effraie les scientifiques
qui demande à diminuer notre
consommation
parmi les exemples relayée dans l'appel
ce graphique qui lie l'augmentation de
la population humaine avec celle des
animaux ruminants
avec cette croissance de l'humanité on
voit une croissance en parallèle de des
animaux d'élevage
on a de plus en plus d'animaux d'élevage
donc souvent en plus dans des conditions
industrielles qui éthiquement sont pas
satisfaisantes et ça sur l'environnement
ça a vraiment un poids qui est très
important tout simplement pour faire un
kilo de boeuf il faut d'abord avoir
nourri le boeuf avec beaucoup de
céréales des céréales que les humains ne
vont pas manger il faut avoir utiliser
énormément d'eau pour les céréales et
pour le boeuf et c'est de l'eau aussi
qui du coup n'est plus disponible
la surpopulation menacent
l'environnement mais une autre
problématique inquiète les scientifiques
les effets du dérèglement climatique qui
alimentent cette croissance
démographique dans des zones plus
difficilement habitable ou touchées par
des phénomènes naturels extrêmes les
populations s'enfuit ces réfugiés
climatiques sont aujourd'hui au nombre
de 20 millions par an qu'on va avoir
systématiquement des gens qui vont plus
avoir assez de ressources sur place et
qu'ils vont devoir partir pour fuir un
climat qui n'est plus du tout favorable
avec les années qui viennent et les
décennies qui viennent
cette situation va empirer et que les
réfugiés climatiques vont être vraiment
de plus en plus nombreux d'ailleurs la
semaine dernière le premier ministre de
nouvelle zélande a créé un nouveau visa
à un visa de réfugiés climatiques ce qui
montre bien que c'est une situation qui
est non pas une projection dans le futur
mais qui est déjà actuelle un nouveau
visa à destination des habitants des
îles du pacifique menacées par la montée
des eaux
comme ici dans les îles marshall où les
hypothèses les plus pessimistes
prévoient une augmentation du niveau de
la mer de plus de 100 cm d'ici la fin du
siècle
une montée des eaux qui entraînerait
l'exode de l'intégralité de la
population
alors à nouvelle zélande créer un statut
de réfugié climatique tout à l'heure
vous pouvez rayer cette inquiétude des
spécialistes sur la question
démographique il faut que vous nous
expliquer pourquoi hervé le bras parce
que d'abord oui ça m'arrive montre
l'entendement spontanée si je puis dire
oui mais oui si on est 10 milliards
comment on fait pour se partager cette
planète pour maintenir un certain nombre
de conditions de vie qui ont fait une
partie de notre civilisation enfin voilà
il ya de chances de questions comme ça
les guerres de la fin de l'accès à l'eau
peuvent tout à fait exister d'un du jour
au lendemain
en plus de la question climatique qui
est en train de créer des réfugiés donc
ce sont des images qui peuvent paraître
effrayantes et qui sont liées au nombre
d'individus c'est lié au nombre
d'individus mais ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure il faut regarder large région
par larges régions alors allons
effectivement si vous prenez par exemple
l'ensemble de l'amérique du sud la
croissance démographique est
pratiquement terminé les prévisions à
l'horizon 2050 montre une très légère
augmentation de la population
si vous prenez la chine c'est exactement
la même chose
donc il reste qu'on pourrait appeler des
hotspots et ses hotspots effectivement
sont des points chauds dans des points
chauds ils sont très dangereux parce
qu'effectivement c'est comme par hasard
là que se produisent les plus gros
trouble actuellement c'est oui c'est
afghanistan-pakistan du nord on est d'un
côté nord de l'inde aussi en partie et
puis c'est de l'autre côté le sahel
et puis une partie de l'afrique
tropicale c'est là qu'on allait les plus
grandes guerres c'est là qu'on a les
plus grands troubles
c'est là qu'on a les maladies qui
surgissent et qui sont difficiles à
régler donc il ya quelque part une sorte
de vérité bien sûr dans ce qui a été dit
sur le risque de surpopulation mais
cette vérité devenu locale simplement
elle est local pour l'instant mais quand
vous pensez qu au niger
vous avez actuellement 20 millions
d'habitants et qu'on en prévoir
l'hypothèse moyenne 70 millions temps 35
en 2050
ça va faire du dégât au tour c'est à
dire ça va faire du dégât dans des pays
qui au contraire commencer à maîtriser
leur fécondité leur croissance on a
quand même envie de vous dire que le
local n'existe plus dans la société
mondialisée
le local est faux c'est faux le local
existe prenez par exemple la question
des réfugiés qui nous coupent agitée est
ce que vous croyez que les réfugiés du
darfour arrive en europe lire et non les
réfugiés de somalie des 60 ha et c'est
donc les problèmes restent quand même
très largement locaux dans la mesure où
ces des populations très pauvres qui
sont frappés bien sûr dès qu'on entre
dans un domaine et ça a était plus tôt
le cas de la syrie où d'abord c'est
encore plus grave que ce qui se passe en
somalie au darfour mais aussi où les
populations sont beaucoup plus éduqués à
ce moment là elles ont les moyens
d'aller plus loin donc là on entre dans
un autre problème la syrie n'était pas
n'avait pas un problème démographique
majeur elle avait un problème politique
majeur françois gemenne si j'ai bien
compris votre première intervention
début d'émission
il est clair que cette question
démographique jette un voile dessus dans
le cadre de la conférence de bonn et de
l'aco 23 je dirais que effectivement ce
qui ce qui pose question à la coop 23 ce
n'est pas tant le nombre absolu de
personnes qui habitent sur la planète
mais ce sont les endroits où elle vivait
le problème et je suis assez d'accord
avec cette nécessité de l' approche
locale ou régionale
le problème c'est que le nombre de
personnes qui habitent dans des zones à
risque ne cesse d'augmenter et que donc
c'est toutes ces personnes deviennent
potentiellement des gens qui risquent de
se déplacer à l'avenir et qui d'ailleurs
se déplacent déjà aujourd'hui ce qu'il
faut bien voir c'est qu'on parle
toujours des réfugiés climatiques comme
quelque chose qui risquerait de se
produire dans le futur c'est déjà une
réalité aujourd'hui est par exemple une
partie des migrants africains qui arrive
en europe pour le moment et que nous
appelons migrants économiques sont aussi
des migrants environnementaux simplement
parce que la moitié la population
africaine environ dépend directement de
l'agriculture de subsistance comme
principale source de revenus est ce
qu'on voit dans nos recherches c'est
qu'on a des parcours migratoire de plus
en plus et aller de plus en plus morcelé
ou d'abord les gens vont quitter la
campagne et envoyer un jeune fils parce
que l'agriculture ne permet plus à la
famille de se nourrir
il va aller chercher du travail en ville
ne va pas toujours est arrivé là parfois
tombés dans les filets de réseaux de
passeurs qui vont l'emmener au niger ou
au mali
et puis finalement il va échouer en
libye est donc cette idée de distinguer
l'économie de l'environnement réalité en
tout cas sur le continent africain n'a
pas tellement de sens parce que le
moment c'est l'économie d'une grande
partie de la population les ressources
de la population dépendent directement
des conditions environnementales et donc
il ne faut pas seulement voir cette
question des réfugiés climatiques comme
quelque chose de futurs ou quelque chose
de limiter aux petits états insulaires
c'est déjà une réalité aujourd'hui
notamment en afrique subsaharienne en
asie du sud et du sud-est et bien sûr
dans les petites delassus l'air c'est à
dire les hotspots les points chauds dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure la question
de l'accès à l'eau à l'eau potable est
une question cruciale
oui alors on enfin l'eau potable et
surtout l'eau pour l'agriculture
oui en fait l'essentiel du prélèvement
d'eau qu'on fait dans une société et
même dans une société comme la nôtre ça
concerne l'agriculture et quand vous
n'avez pas assez d'eau chez vous va vous
pouvez si vous avez de quoi le payer
importer des denrées agricoles de chez
les autres et quand vous avez plus cet
argent là vous avez des problèmes c'est
soit dit en passant ce qui s'est passé
au maghreb en 2011 où vous avez le
maghreb est un endroit qui dans le cadre
des projections climatiques va
s'assécher
c'est déjà à l'oeuvre et quand ça ça
sèche ça pousse un peu moins bien
toutes choses égales par ailleurs et
donc vous avez besoin d'un peu plus
d'importation de nourriture si vous
arrivez à vous les payez ce qu'on a
appelé les émeutes de la faim alors ça a
été des émeutes de la faim parce que les
recettes à l'exportation ont baissé il y
avait moins de touristes et on était
dans la suite de la crise de 2009
l'alimentation a fortement augmenté
notamment suite à une sécheresse
remarquable qui a eu en russie en 2010
ça a supprimé les exportations russes
cette année là le marché des céréales
est très sensible à des petites
variations de la production disponible à
l'exportation les prises sont envolés et
on a eu des émeutes de la faim donc ça
existe déjà ces problèmes là et on s'est
retrouvé avec une révolution et ont une
envie une révolution léger pouilly et
pas au maroc où les problèmes
d'importation d'alimentation sont
beaucoup moins qu'on ne veuille pas en
algérie qui pouvaient payer ses
importations avec ses exportations
d'hydrocarbures on découpe des
conséquences que vous êtes déjà en train
d'évoquer je suis en train de dire que
le problème est déjà à nos portes et les
déterminants du problème font qu'il n'a
aucune raison de ne pas empirer aucune
parce qu'il ya plus en plus de monde
parce que ça va s'assécher parce que
l'algérie va perdre progressivement ses
recettes à l'exportation parce qu'elle a
passé son pic de production de pétrole
et de gaz
donc enfin pic de production algérien
est passé oui donc c'est donc c'est
quelque chose si vous agréger les deux
où il est passé
si vous donc si vous regardons été
déterminant à l'oeuvre n'ont aucune
raison de nous amener vers un problème
plus simple à résoudre et l'eau est
intimement lié quelque part à la
question du climat vous avez l'eau s'il
pleut donc la question de l'accès à
l'eau et la question du changement
climatique sont des sujets qui sont
extrêmement imbriquées bon ça veut dire
de toute façon vous nous annoncez des
phénomènes de migration important qui
viendra lorsque je suis en train de dire
par ailleurs pour rebondir sur ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure c'est que jamais
su si on disait le bras ou le brazil le
braz le braz par douala excusez moi la
version moderne bretonne alors là on est
sérieux c'est que vous pouvez pas juger
du résultat de l'expérience avant
qu'elle soit terminée oui or une partie
des conséquences du fait qu'on soit
aujourd'hui quelques milliards sur terre
vous allez le voir avec des effets
différés le changement climatique est un
parfait exemple
il faut quand même savoir le répète je
l'aide à 10 sur ce plateau le temps de
résidence du surplus de co2 qu'on met
dans l'air aujourd'hui c'est des
milliers d'années donc il ya un effet
totalement irréversible dans cette
affaire et des effets qui vont être pour
une large partie différée donc savoir si
aujourd'hui on peut dire qu'on est trop
nombreux malheureusement faut attendre
le résultat l'expérience vous le saurez
à la fin si on avait été trop nombreux
donc c'est juste pour dire ça vous
décrivez une partie de poker
exactement c'est à dire que je suis en
train de dire nous n'avons pas et nous
ne serons jamais en mesure d'avoir en
temps réel la totalité des événements
des éléments qui permettent de dire à la
à 6 milliards 752 millions on vient de
passer le seuil
je vais vous les avez jamais tout le
monde commence à dire c'est trop tard
alors pour éviter une partie des
génériques c'est totalement
pardonnez-moi des essais alors je vois
très bien le lit d un mais désespérant
contre-productif et je pense que ça
contribue très largement à baisser les
bras donc je sais trop tard ça dépend ce
qu'on appelle trop tard si la question s
est trop tard pour garder une espèce
humaine
là je vais vous dire non non c'est pas
trop tard l'espèce humaine va passer à
travers le problème j'ai aucun si on dit
c'est trop tard pour que chaque et
représentants de l'espèce humaine passe
totalement indemne à travers le problème
je dis oui ça c'est déjà le cas bien
cela et après la question c'est qu'est
ce qu'on est prêt à faire aujourd'hui
comme effort supplémentaire pour éviter
un supplément de problème demain et
c'est difficile quand vous n'avez pas
une appréciation très fine plus de ce à
quoi peut ressembler le supplément
problème c'est tout le sujet dans cette
affaire de changement climatique ce qui
cause de problèmes c'est ce qui nous
rend la vie si douce aujourd'hui est la
conséquence du problème et pas facile à
illustrer pas facile à incarner pas
facile a attribué à celui qui va causer
le trouble en voilà donc cet aprem
compliqué régional hervé le bras oui je
serais plus optimiste parce qu'au fond
en 1798
quand malthus plus harry son livre il
pense qu'elle beaucoup de suite j'ai un
énorme problème il ya trop d'habitants
en angleterre ils sont à peu près 10
millions ce que oublie malthus c'est
qu'il va y avoir des progrès des progrès
des tarifs il ya des famines de patates
dont elle évalue à quelques il ya
quelques familles va y avoir permis
grimpent et les états unis
il ya un profond il ya un problème lié à
un développement majeur qui arrive au
début du 19e siècle
c'est la découverte des engrais minéraux
j'ai à l'époque malthus résonne comme si
le seul regret était d'origine animale
et dans ce cas là il a raison mais de ce
point de vue là il les retardataires il
pouvait pas voir venir le coup mais ça
change absolument t au point que
d'ailleurs dans sa correspondance avec
engels marx estime qu'on pourra
multiplier les rendements agricoles par
10000 là une golf le calme un tout petit
peu quand même mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que il me semble problème qui est
par derrière
d'abord on peut croire qu'il y aura du
progrès scientifique dans les années à
venir
et surtout il ya une chose dont on a
quand même assez peu parler aujourd'hui
c'est la majorité d'un question vient de
l'inégalité des consommations sur la
terre et c'est au fond plus généralement
la question d'inégalité c'est je pense
ceci a une médecine à appliquer au monde
c'est de lutter contre les questions de
d'inégalités contre l'augmentation des
inégalités dans la plupart des pays la
france est un des pays où le sang - est
un des pays où les inégalités augmentent
le peut dire le plus lentement mais
quand vous voyez aux états unis ou en
angleterre
or ce sont les plus riches qui de loin
consomment le plus vous devez avoir des
chiffres meilleurs que moi sur les
empreintes écologiques mais on parlait
du niger l'empreinte écologique d'un
habitant du nid
est très faible comparé à l'empreinte
écologique d'un habitant de la france où
surtout des états unis donc là dedans
il me semble qu'il ya bien sûr il ya des
problèmes qui sont des problèmes
physiques qui sont des problèmes
techniques mais il ya aussi des
problèmes qui sont des problèmes sociaux
c'est comment faire que les sociétés
elles soient plus justes parce que sinon
la course à la richesse va augmenter
dans tous les pays et c'est ce que
disait françois gemenne tout à l'heure
c'est les pays les plus pauvres vois pas
pourquoi on leur empêcherait de devenir
aussi riche que les autres bien sûr
françois gemenne alors est ce que ces
questions à la fois de partage de
politique et aussi de progrès
scientifiques qui viennent d'être
abordée notamment par hervé le braz sont
débattues en ce moment à la coop 23 bien
sûr il est question évidemment de
progrès scientifique et de protéger
technologique mais je crois qu'elle
essentiellement c'est une question
politique en réalité c'est vrai qu'à la
coupe 23 ici on a un peu un sentiment
d'inertie globale et donc on voit tous
les indicateurs qui passent au rouge
et c'est comme si nous étions un peu
collectivement paralysé alors bien sûr
il ya plein de petites initiatives de
projets qui se monte mais c'est vrai que
globalement la négociation semble
complètement atone semble complètement
amorphe et je crois que c'est parce
qu'elle n'est pas encore suffisamment
politique c'est à dire que on considère
encore la question du climat est plus
globalement la question de
l'environnement comme une question à
part délier des grands choix collectifs
alors qu'il faut bien se rendre compte
qu aujourd'hui tous les grands enjeux du
21e siècle
que ce soit la gestion des migrations la
question de l'agriculture et
l'alimentation les grandes questions de
santé publique de sécurité et même de
terrorisme vont être affectés par la
question du climat est donc je crois on
parler de ce qui peut nous donner espoir
est ce qui peut nourrir motivé je crois
qu'aujourd'hui l'impératif c'est de
repolitiser ces questions de se rendre
compte que la plupart de nos grands
choix collectifs du 21e siècle seront
affectés par la question du climat est
donc il faut poser ses choix collectifs
à l'aune de la question climatique et
sans ne fait pas encore on considère
toujours le climat et l'environnement
dans une sorte de boîte à part un peu
technocratique et séparée des choix
collectifs et ce qu'on interroge madame
merkel sur la façon dont à la relancer
notamment les énergies carbonées en
décidant de se passer du nucléaire dans
son pays alors ça a été une grosse
question évidemment ici à l'accord 23
c'était la politique énergétique de
l'allemagne
on sent que l'allemagne est aujourd'hui
un peu de mal à atteindre ses propres
objectifs est certain que ça affaiblit
la position de leadership allemande
notamment au sein de l'union européenne
il y a eu des campagnes d'activistes de
greenpeace notamment qui ont réclamé la
fin immédiate des mines à charbon de
l'allemagne angela merkel a reconnu à
demi mots que ça ne devrait forcément
arriver et que la question des mines de
charbon n'était pas soutenable dans le
long terme
mais on sent aujourd'hui que l'allemagne
est effectivement encore un peu de mal
sur sa politique énergétique notamment
en raison de la fermeture accélérée des
centrales nucléaires après la
catastrophe de fukushima et quelque part
au défaut d'anticipation vers les
énergies renouvelables
c'est pas très facile de donner des
leçons de morale annales comme quand on
relance soit même en étant la première
puissance industrielle européenne sont
énergies carbonées non oui il y a mais
on voit bien l'enseignement des causes
qui était la fermeture des rapides ça a
été dit des usines des centrales
nucléaires donc il faut trouver un
produit de substitution le développement
des énergies renouvelables et qui est
assez rapide en allemagne ne l'est pas
assez pour compenser donc on passe au
charbon en plus de ça il ya une vieille
habitude du charbon dans les pays à
partir de l'allemagne la pologne est
bien bien pires que l'allemagne de ce
point de vue là et s'autorise de
l'exemple allemand d'ailleurs un dernier
mot oui en fait il faut il faut se
rappeler que l'énergie c'est pas un truc
qu'on achète comme on achète une paire
de chaussettes
c'est en physique la marque de la
transformation donc me fait l'énergie
c'est ce qui permet d'organiser un
système de transformation que parfois on
appelle système économique et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la production
économique mesurée avec l'indicateur
classique qu'on appelle le pib est au
premier rang
je dis bien au premier ordre
proportionnelle à la quantité d'énergie
que vous rentrez dans un pays parce que
c'est ça qui permet de faire tourner
toutes les machines d'avancé tous les
camions et c'est donc en fait et c'est
là je rebondis sur ce qu'elle a dit
françois gemenne résoudre le problème du
changement climatique dans un monde qui
dépend à 80% des énergies fossiles
en même temps que vous voulez augmenter
la taille de l'économie
on est dans la quadrature du cercle non
c'est impossible là c'est à peu de
choses près d'être en train de me dire
que par exemple si si si demain on a
plus de pétrole la france perd quoi 90%
de sa richesse nationale
bah si demain on a plus de pétrole vous
n'avez plus de nourriture acheminée dans
les villes parce que ça arrive par
camion
vous avez plus d engrais vous n'avez
plus d'engrais enfin c'est du gaz ça
surtout vous n'avez plus de tracteurs et
vous n'avez pas les gens pour passer la
binette en quantité dans les champs et
c'est donc vous avez le pays qui
s'effondre dernier reportage de cette
émission c'est un nouveau terme mais
l'on méditerranée et you can ouragan en
anglais on parle maintenant de merican
la coulée de boue dramatique que vient
de connaître la grèce on serait
probablement un exemple explications
avec sébastien poker un torrent de boue
traverse des quartiers habités emporte
les voitures et par sa force
dévastatrice des cars et des camions
hier en grèce anea par amos et mènera en
grande banlieue d'athènes
sur la côte des milliers d'habitations
ont été inondées en quelques secondes
les eaux après des pluies diluviennes
ont surpris et fait 14 victimes
les ambulances services de secours et
pelleteuses étaient à pied d'oeuvre dans
les rues recouvertes d'une épaisse
couche de boue les habitants peinent à
se déplacer découvre l'ampleur des
dégâts et témoigne de la violence de cet
épisode météo
c'est venu comme un tsunami
oui comme un tsunami pas comme une
rivière tout n'est que destruction à
désastre biblique le phénomène météo
qu'a connues la grèce est un medicaid
un néologisme mehdi pour méditerranée
kane pour hurricane ouragan en anglais
le voici sur la carte
il s'agit d'une dépression subtropicale
qui se forme en mer méditerranée
lorsqu'elle est plus chaude que l'air
une dépression à coeur chaud un peu
comme un cyclone mais moins puissants
ici on voit la force des vents et en
particulier des rafales qui s'organise
de façon très symétriques autour d'un
oeil ces vents peuvent être tempétueux
autour de cet oeil avec des rafales qui
dépasse les 100 voire 150 kilomètres par
heure
des vents violents des pluies
torrentielles qui cause des inondations
impressionnantes comme en grèce et des
vagues qui peuvent aller en pleine mer
jusqu'à 8 mètres de haut
causant sur le littoral une hausse du
niveau de la mer comme ici à cannes en
2010 la france a connu un autre
événement de ce type toujours à cannes
en 2011
c'est de medicaid n'ont fait aucune
victime mais il se pourrait bien que ce
phénomène météo autrement appelée
cyclone tropical de méditerranée soient
de plus en plus fréquent avec le
réchauffement climatique
on se demande si on dépend de découvrir
en fait nos nos propres à gand mais
version méditerranée vous voit s'ouvrir
aux ouragans c'est 100 km heure c'est
quand même pas un ouragan et là il y
avait la pression au centre de la haute
pression on était à 990 tôt pascal on
est on est un ouragan ses 900
dans les très violents 920 à 930 car on
n'est pas en train de parler de la même
chose
par contre ça ça fait penser aux
épisodes cévenols
non il ya des grandes quantités de pluie
qui tombe sur les reliefs et ça c'est un
phénomène qu'on connaît déjà mais dont
un certain nombre de gens pensent que il
pourrait s'intensifier dans le cadre
d'un climat qui se réchauffe parce que
la différence de température mère terre
peut augmenter à la faveur du
réchauffement et c'est un moteur on va
dire de ce genre de ce genre d'événement
on voit aussi que c'est lié à ce qu'on
appelle l'artificialisation des sols
c'est à dire que le mode d'écoulement
des eaux dans cas de pluies très
violentes est bloqué parce que les
anciennes rivières ont été ou bien
bétonné ou bien transformer en petit ego
et est donc l'eau dévale nous donner non
seulement pu absorbée par la terre
mais elle ne rencontre plus de moyens de
s'échapper d'ailleurs on voit très bien
sur les images que c'est typiquement un
problème urbain ici la terre est très
sèche comme après l'été gambienne
connaître où il a très peu plus la dur
coup la terre elle-même est
raisonnablement imperméable et n'absorbe
pas les précipitations
vous vous trompez entend scientifique le
terme de medicaid qui essaie de nous
faire comprendre quelque chose
vous trouvez ça au raisonnable ou penser
que c'est une facilité avec cécile de
langage pour traduire des phénomènes
météo qui existe de fait on peut dire
que c'est une facilité de langage mais
qu'elle n'est pas c'est pas
catastrophique comme facilité de langage
enfin je veux dire ça illustre bien le
fait que c'est un phénomène extrême mais
que ses propres à la méditerranée cela
étant encore une fois ça n'a pas la
force des vents d'un droit dans don
enfin si on s'en prend plusieurs sur la
tête à tête aussi forcé à la réflexion
je ne sais pas sûr sur des questions
dont on débat ce soit ou dont on ne
débat pas en partie à la côte 23 noms
c'est une bonne question
il se trouve que commence en avoir
quelques cheveux blancs je me rappelle
que les tempêtes de 99 avait fait naître
un grand débat sur est ce que c'est le
réchauffement climatique ou est-ce que
c'est pas le réchauffement climatique
et puis après le souffle et
raisonnablement retombées espère que
pendant longtemps
il ya eu un certain nombre d'autres
phénomènes extrêmes et la question ne
revenez pas vraiment sur les écrans
radar donc je ne sais pas répondre à la
question qui est est ce que ce genre de
choses fait réfléchir je suis pas
complètement sûr que la réponse soit oui
françois gemenne je me tourne à nouveau
vers vous ce que j'imaginais les
médicales n'ont pas atteint la bonne
ville de bonn je vous sens quand même
depuis le début de l'émission assez
pessimiste sur la façon dont ça ça
travaille en ce moment à bonn sur cette
coque 23 et le jeu en vous écoutant tout
à l'heure je me disais mais on a
l'impression que en fait ils travaillent
pas ou s'ils travaillent ils ne vont pas
donner une issue à ce travail qui est en
train de se faire on est d'une certaine
façon à ce qu'ils on a l'impression est
ce qu'ils sont pas en train d'enterrer
pardonnez-moi notre kop 21
d'une certaine manière si et on a
effectivement l'impression
malheureusement que les que les coptes
sont un peu entré en léthargie depuis la
cap 21 et que beaucoup de gouvernements
considèrent un peu qu'ils ont fait leur
part du travail qu'ils peuvent rayer la
question climatique de leur liste des
choses à faire et que maintenant c'est à
la société civile de prendre le relais
et donc ça donne des négociations
politiques qui ont donné l'impression
d'être un peu vidé de leur substance ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
l'accord de paris c'est pas la ligne
d'arrivée sur le point de départ c'est
un accord dont on pourra penser du monde
du moins bon mais en tout cas c'est le
meilleur qu'on pouvait produire la
diplomatie et le drame c'est qu'il
arrive
21 ans trop tard ont hérité l'accord de
paris c'est le cadre dans lequel se doit
se penser l'action internationale c'est
l'accord qu'on aurait dû avoir à la coop
1 et pas à la coop 21 et donc en réalité
c'est maintenant que tout commence
et beaucoup de gouvernements considèrent
que c'est déjà fini c'est à mon avis ça
le vrai problème des coques pour le
moment il faut d'urgence les remettre en
mouvement et d'une certaine manière les
repolitiser aussi alors on a deux
petites minutes pour conclure en plateau
c'est la question c'est quelle est la
prochaine étape là qu'est ce qui se
passe est ce qu'on peut avoir une coque
23 qui échoue réellement et en quoi
ça aggrave la situation dont on nous dit
en ce moment la une de la presse et avec
des appels de scientifiques quasiment
qu'il est déjà pratiquement trop tard le
gros enjeu de cette coop 23 c'était de
voir si les gouvernements à lettre
d'accord de revoir à la hausse
significativement les engagements pris à
paris avant 2020 comme je les dis c'est
la condition sinequanone si on veut se
donner une chance d'atteindre l'objectif
des deux degrés nous sommes aujourd'hui
jeudi soir il reste un jour de
négociation et pour le moment les
gouvernements ne sont pas d'accord de
revoir à la hausse ses objectifs
ça veut dire effectivement qu'on peut
enterrer l'objectif de l'accord de paris
et ça c'est une tragédie
bon on a compris que l'on pouvait trop
éventuellement sur la planète mais de
toute façon il fallait il allait falloir
sauver cette humanité comme com comment
on s'y prend
hervé le bras je pense d'abord de ne pas
trop charger la question démographique
c'est un moyen d'échapper aux autres
questions qui sont cons a soulevé durant
et c'est une échappatoire c'est une
échappée à la fois une donnée objective
c'est très clairement et on l'a dit
qu'on ne peut pas régler cette question
par des politiques autoritaires c'est
des questions qui vont toucher jusqu'à
la liberty des couples d'avoir des
enfants dont vous nous dit que c'est pas
réaliste vouloir vous dites que c'est
passé aux questions de composition de la
consommation notamment il ya une
allusion à cela de la consommation de
viande qui est une grosse mangeuse si
l'on peut dire de calories végétales et
puis aussi aux aux questions de
d'inégalités qui sont à la l'une des
sources les plus importantes de la
montée de la consommation donc quelque
part je me méfie toujours de ces grands
appels sur la démographie parce que non
seulement ils évitent ces sujets plus
lourd
et puis aussi comme je les dis au début
ils ne regardent pas dans dans le détail
ce qui se passe en démographie chacun
doit prendre sa part de l'effort
oui c'est ça le fond du problème en fait
le diable est dans les détails dans
cette histoire oui c'est à dire que je
suis le président d'une démocratie donc
élus dont je vous rappelle que je suis
l'exécuteur testamentaire de mes
électeurs inscrits comme ça que ça
marche et et qui peuvent décider de ne
pas me repr désir d un pauvre con
et caetera et de faire baisser dans les
sondages les cotes de popularité et une
fois que j'ai dit qu'on allait baisser
les émissions d'un pays ça veut dire que
ça va se traduire dans des mesures
concrètes dans ce que les gens mangent
la manière dont il se déplace la manière
dont ils habitent et ce qu'ils en droit
d'acheter au magasin en fin de droits ce
qu'ils peuvent acheter au magasin parce
que les industriels doivent bien le
fabriquer et donc là où ça commence à
devenir compliqué c'est que on va
désagréger ce débat à l'échelle d'un
pays
chacun va dire c'est l'autre qui doit
porter l'effort en premier enfin bref
donc c'est là que ça devient compliqué
ça demande beaucoup de force de
constance et de compréhension du
problème à traiter
et malheureusement le pessimisme à la
coop et pour partie le reflet du
pessimisme qu'on peut de temps en temps
avoir sur les quelques éléments que je
viens d'évoquer
merci beaucoup jean marc jancovici avait
le braz et françois gemenne excellent
correspondant depuis bonn rediffusion de
notre débat aux alentours de 22h30 comme
chaque soir assure ses news l'info du
vrai continue à 20h30 à 20h20 très
exactement la culture nous recevons ce
soir guillaume gallienne de la comédie
française pour son dernier film avec
adeline d'hermy de la comédie-française
émotions et tensions dans ce film
nouveau intitulé marilyn mais tout de
suite 20 heures l'événement
[Musique]